bishop robert emmett barron is a
us-based prelate of the roman catholic
church
serving as an auxiliary bishop of the
archdiocese of los angeles
he was a professor of systematic
theology at university of saint mary of
the lake from 1992 until 2015
upgraded in 2008 to the inaugural
francis cardinal george professor of
faith and culture
he founded the catholic ministry word on
fire
which employs traditional and digital
media to describe the doctrines of
catholicism to the general public
word on fire published the 10-part
series catholicism which was broadcast
on pbs in 2011
and which bishop baron hosted
he's published a number of books
including catholicism a journey to the
heart of the faith
vibrant paradoxes the both slash and of
catholicism and very recently
your life is worth living with fulton
sheen published on march 5th 2019
he has a substantive youtube presence
with a total viewership of 30 million
and is well known on facebook as well
with 1.5 million followers
clearly bishop baron is among the rare
religious figures managing a substantial
public impact
in the present world
it's very nice to see you i've been
looking forward to our meeting for quite
a long time yeah me too thanks for
having me on the show
yeah well people keep writing and saying
you have to talk to bishop baron and
then they come up to me and they say you
have to talk to bishop baron
well i mean the same thing from the
other side everyone's telling me to talk
to you so
it must be in god's providence i suppose
at least we can hope that that's the
case yeah so
why
do people want us to talk as far as
you're concerned
yeah you know
i'm not entirely sure but i would say
i think you've opened a lot of doors for
people to religion
uh in an era when you know the new
atheists are are very influential among
young people and i think you've
opened doors that legitimize at least uh
reapproaching these great issues and
questions and texts
and so i i'm doing it i suppose in a
more explicit way but you're i think
paving the way for an awful lot of
people at least to reconsider religion
so maybe they find that intriguing and
probably the fact that we're both
uh coming out of an academic uh
background but then trying to reach out
you know more widely through the social
media so there's that in common but uh
you know i used to speak for myself
that's what i see in you that's been so
powerful uh
because in the wake of the new atheist
critique i mean i just find that so uh
such a desert opens up for young people
and and i deal with young people all the
time and i hear the echoes of hitchens
and dawkins and sam harris all the time
but it's such a finely bleak view you
know and religion speaks to these
deepest longings of the heart and i
think you've for a lot of people made
that again possible at least to think
coherently and rationally about those
things
so i found that very uplifting and
helpful and i think a lot of people have
too
if maybe they see a point of contact
there between the two of us maybe you
know it's funny because
i've received
letters from
people of different faiths from all over
the world eh like
yeah surprising number of people
catholics and
a lot of orthodox christians a lot of
orthodox jews a substantial number of
muslims far more than i would have ever
suspected yeah um
protestants and
and and monks and
and
buddhists and
hindus who are
all following the
lecture series i did on genesis back in
and also you know a tremendous number of
atheists i would say yeah they probably
outnumber the religious people
surprisingly enough and they've said
that
the tact that i've taken
which is
i would say kind of a fine balancing
line between the religious and the
psychological yeah to
well i guess it's it's it's had the same
effect on the people that i've been
talking to that it's had on
on me
like these stories
yeah had a profound effect on me well
you know i've talked about you actually
to the american bishops because
i'm on this i'm the chair of the
evangelization catechesis committee so
the bishops concerned about how we
propagate the faith today you know and
i've laid out for them a lot of the grim
statistics and they are grim about
especially young people leaving the
catholic church you know
for everyone that joined six are leaving
now we have the highest
rate of people leaving
anyway i've gone through some of those
stats but then i've i've signaled signs
of hope
and you're one of them i said the fact
that this gentleman who's speaking about
i'd say spiritual things and certainly
now about the bible in a way that is
smart and compelling especially young
people
is hopeful
uh so
many might be leaving you know official
religion but the religious questions
have not left their minds
and i think you're addressing that in a
way that's very uh provocative and
compelling and it's given me a sort of
renewed courage to say well why can't we
do the same thing why have we
it it's our book i mean let's face it
the bible is the book the churches you
know produced it's the heart of the
church's life
but why is this someone who's at least
in a formal sense outside the church
doing a better job than we are at
explicating it
and so i i've taken it to be a state of
hope
it's a mystery well i feel too
that
my position
outside
the church yeah is actually critical to
the success of what i'm doing
you know people
have tried to pin me down multiple times
with regards to my
belief in god i actually did a two-hour
lecture in
this was a 70-minute lecture in
australia about that question because i
thought about it a lot and about
i've always felt
imposed upon i would say and boxed in
when people ask me that question but i
finally figured out that
i didn't really feel
that i had the
moral
right
to
make a claim about belief
in god
i mean that's not a trivial thing to
to let's say
proclaim
yeah you know because it's not merely a
matter of
stating in some verbal manner that i
am willing to
agree
semantically with a set of doctrines it
means that you have to
live
you have to commit to living a certain
way
yeah and
the demand of that life is so
stringent
and so all-consuming
and and you're so unlikely to live up to
it
that to
make the claim
that you believe
i think is a
to me it's smacks of a kind of
i mean i understand why people do it and
this isn't a criticism of people's
statement of faith but
for me the
critical
element of
belief is action
and the
requirements of christianity are so
incredibly demanding
that i don't
see how you can proclaim yourself a
believer without
being terrified of
immediately being struck down by
lightning or some cosmic
you know there's a lot to that i mean
there's a lot to it the story that i've
always loved about origen the great
church father whom jung loved by the way
i mean jung saw the church fathers some
of the first great psychologists and
origin sermons on genesis exodus are
like yours in many ways i mean i don't
know if you've been reading him
explicitly but that's sort of
psychodynamic and spiritual reading
origins all over that but the story is
about this young guy in gregory who
comes to origin to learn the doctrine of
the christians and origen said to him
first you must come and live our life
and then you'll understand our doctrine
and that young kid gregory became saint
gregory thalmaturgas he becomes a great
saint of the church
but he had to get into the life first
and there's a lot to that i think the
practices of christianity they get into
your body before they get into your mind
um
it's also true i think that when you
take away a lot of practices that
surround certain doctrines the doctrine
fades from people's minds
uh when i was a kid there was still the
practice around the blessed sacrament
people you know with genuflections and
before you entered the pew in church you
would genuflect
in fact they say that
catholics are my of my parents
generation when they come into a movie
theater to see a movie in the rows of of
seats they would genuflect before they
got to the role but see that means this
thing was so in their bodies you know
but that practice was communicating to
the mind the importance of what's in
front of them well the same is true
really of all the doctrines you know
god in some ways is a function of this
manner of life uh and so i've emphasized
that actually a lot in my own work the
postmoderns who have influenced
christianity are very strong on that two
practices i mean my take jordan is that
there's a there's a hundred ways in to
the question of god there's all kinds of
paths you know one of them being just
that ritual
the body
the moral life is a way in to look at
the saints and try to be a saint is a
great way in
um
jared manley hopkins the great jesuit
poet
uh who was a convert under john henry
newman so he himself went through this
process of discovering the faith but
someone came to him and said you know
i'm really wrestling with belief in god
and he said
give alms.
he didn't provide an argument or prove
he said do something and of course if
you play the whole thing out i mean if
god is love that's what god is then
performing an act of love gets you
closer to god than almost anything else
and so the giving of alms can
lead you into that sacred space
now the questing mind i mean then wants
to ask all kinds of questions about it
and ground it
so you know feed as querents intellectum
of enzo might faith seeking
understanding that's where theology
philosophy will come in
but i think there's
i've been talking to my audiences
practically about certain elements of
let's say judeo-christian fundamental
belief so
you know
i
spent
i think two and a half hours the first
biblical lecture i did on the first
sentence of genesis and then tried to
take the opening chapters apart in great
detail but
some very interesting
propositions from a psychological and
philosophical perspective in genesis i
mean
i look at it sort of technically
in some sense as a statement about the
nature of being i mean
what genesis reveals to me is that
there has to be a structure to encounter
possibility
or that there is a structure that
encounters possibility that's part of
that's built into reality itself
and that structure is god the father and
that structure uses a process and the
process is the logos and the logos is
something like courageous truthful
communication it's the word but it's
much more than that
and it uses that to encounter this
potential and to generate order
and
it seems to me that that's that's
psychologically akin to what human
beings do with their own consciousness
you know the the new atheist types and
the materialist scientists
tend to consider human beings
deterministic organisms but my
understanding of neuropsychology is that
the only time that we are
deterministic organisms is when
circuits for specific tasks have been
built up through lengthy practice and
can be run automatically
much of the time in our lives and i talk
to my audiences about this
what we do is we wake up in the morning
our consciousness reappears on the
plane of being let's say and
what we face in front of us is an
unstructured
and potential filled chaos yeah and and
our consciousness determines the manner
in which that
potential transforms itself into the
actuality of order into the present and
the past and and i think everyone
understands that we treat each other
that way like we treat each other we
treat ourselves as if
we are responsible
for what we bring into existence that's
part of our moral responsibility
we treat each other as if that's part of
what makes us worthwhile as creatures
right that's part of our value
we treat ourselves as if
the nature of what we bring into being
is determined by our choices between
good and evil
and we treat other people the same way
like you can't have a
friendship with someone
if you don't believe that they
have
that power of choice and
that capacity for morality you're you
you don't have there's any respect for
them and they won't interact with you
and so you can't found a friendship on
that and you can't found a family
and
you can't found a
society or without the fundamental
presupposition that
individuals this is another element of
course of
the presuppositions in genesis that that
the individual is somehow
made in the image of god if god is that
which confronts potential and generates
order and then more you know because god
says too in genesis that
every time he constructs something
that's new and orderly
using the logos he says and it was good
and that's so fascinating to me because
it's repeated so many times because
what it implies is that
if you confront if the potential
of being is confronted
with what's good and truthful and
courageous then what
emerges as a consequence is good
and i also believe that to be the case
for individuals if you
confront the world
in a manner that's
cane-like
bitter
incapable of making the proper
sacrifices
enraged jealous
uh outraged at the suffering of
existence and its essential unfairness
then you become vengeful and bitter and
murderous and genocidal and
yeah
that seems like no
positive
way forward that's no bargain yeah with
the with the new atheist types you know
they demolish the metaphysics
without really thinking it through i
think
and they leave people with
with nothing yeah but nothing is so
empty that it it just produces
it really produces pain for people like
yeah i've talked to many many many
people including atheists who have been
vastly relieved to find
some deeper meaning in
our culture
every day i deal with that is people
that they feel obligated intellectually
to accept the new atheist you know
conclusions but then their whole soul is
rebelling against it and i would say for
obvious reasons
you know what's very interesting to me
jordan is i've got a colleague chris
kasor who teaches at lmu he's written on
your stuff and he said what peterson is
doing is what the church fathers would
have called the tropological reading of
the scriptures you know the four senses
you've got the literal historical
interpretation you've got the
allegorical so it has to do with jesus
you have the anagogical having to do
with the journey to heaven but the
tropological they would have seen is the
moral sense so what it has to do about
our moral lives and i think in in our
categories say maybe the psychological
life etc and so i think what you just
proposed there is a cool you know
through a tropological
reading of those texts
i mean i'd without denying it i'd press
on the more metaphysical stuff uh
josef ratzinger who became pope benedict
xvi did a wonderful meditation on
genesis saying that to say i believe in
god is to say i believe in the primacy
of logos over and against mere matter so
over and against a merely materialist
view that what's more metaphysically
primordial is logos and he would stress
intelligibility that the fact that god
speaks the world into being means it's
marked in every nook and cranny by
something like intelligibility which in
turn would ground anything like the
sciences i mean any
scientist goes out to meet a world that
at least he or she assumes is
intelligible you know so
the the intelligibility of things the
the rational structure within being is
coming from from the logos but the other
thing that i think is really intriguing
about the genesis that opening move
is the dethroning of all the false
claims to divinity
so all the things that come forth from
god you know from
sun and moon and and the animals and so
on so forth were all things that were
worshipped in various cultures in the
ancient world so the author is saying no
no no no these things are not themselves
ultimate they're not the logos from
which all things come but then the cool
twist to me it's not just a no because
i see catholics get this because the way
that text is structured it's
liturgically structured it's like a
liturgical procession everything coming
forth in this ordered way
at the end of the procession i come
human beings right so at the end of a
liturgical procession is the one who
will lead the praise
and so the point there this goes back to
augustine and people like that
the point is none of these things is god
but all these things belong in a chorus
of praise of the true god
led by
us so and there's the human role is to
give proper praise to god well you know
there's critics for example there's a
critic in canada
um
a well-known environmentalist david
suzuki yeah who believes that
one of the sins of the judeo-christian
perspective is that it gave human beings
dominion over the world
and yeah and and uh um
the the philosopher um
the german philosopher
what's his name that went down yes
um the phenomenologist whisser
no his student heidegger heidegger
you know believed that
the judeo-christian texts have given us
the right to treat the world as if it's
produce you know there yeah but that's
it's getting exactly backwards isn't it
it's this deep respect for our fellow
creatures as part of the chorus of
praise and the dominion is not
domination i think it's that kind of
right ordering and the thing there is
there's been a lot of interesting
studies recently of the temple the
ancient temple and
how it was covered inside and out by
symbols of the cosmos you know animals
and plants and planets and stars and so
on the idea being when israel gathered
for right praise
it was the whole universe being gathered
for right praise now look at that in the
gothic churches you go to notre domino
but it's not an anthropocentric thing
you've got the planets and stars and
astrological signs and animals galore
because the cathedral was the successor
of the temple the place of right praise
and it's drawing creation in see i think
it's much more modernity that is is
rough on nature and rough on the animal
kingdom thomas aquinas is not i mean go
back to the the pre-modern christian
thinkers
they're not anti-nature on the contrary
because the biblical vision is salvation
is a is a cosmic reality god's trying to
save all of his creation that's the noah
story is god
the ark is like a floating temple right
so it's a little microcosm of the right
order of things led by
noah's family
yeah by a family right properly ordered
and what are they concerned about the
animals they're concerned about life
that god created that's why the ark
becomes a symbol of the church so all
the churches are meant to look like
ships you have like nave right the ship
the central isle of a church
but they're meant to be a little
floating temple where creation is
honored and preserved so i i would blame
interesting too to note that in the
noah's story that there's a tremendous
emphasis on the idea that
like noah who's someone who
like adam before the fall walked with
god
was capable because he could act nobly
and courageously and truthfully and also
put his family together he was actually
capable of shepherding
the complex creation of being in its
totality for a period of absolute chaos
right i look at
the
environmental
challenges let's say that we face today
because of the complexity of
the 9 billion of us or the 9 billion
that there will be and
the necessity of making sure that
everyone has adequate security and
shelter and food and freedom
yeah i see that the proper
pathway forward to dealing with that is
for people to
put themselves together and to put their
families together and the communities
together and that
the consequence of that the natural
consequence of that
adoption of ultimate responsibility
would be
the extension of care
beyond
the immediate beyond the social even and
so that everything does depend
i would say
and this is something i learned
from young
from young was that
far more than we think depends on the
orderly
progression
and care of the soul all of it depends
on it and you know when i talk to my
audiences it's so interesting and i
think it might be something that the
church is missing if i could be so go
ahead
well
you know
i've talked to about 150 live audiences
now about this sort of thing
independent of all my classroom lectures
and
i'll tell you
i i tell people i suggest to people that
the really the ancient
idea that life is suffering
and and that it's tainted by malevolence
that there's no more true ideas than
that in some base sense
and that that's something that everyone
has to contend with and
if you don't contend with it properly
then you become embittered and and you
work to make things worse and everyone
understands that everyone knows that's
true
and then i suggest to them that
the proper way out of that isn't the
pursuit of material satisfaction or
impulsive happiness or rights
from the individual perspective the
adoption of responsibility
and i'll tell you every single time i
talk about that
you can hear a pin drop in the
auditorium yeah i believe and i think
one of the things that
the church has failed to
communicate
properly is that
you need a noble goal in life to
buttress yourself against its
catastrophe and i mean abel is a good
example of that in the abel and cain
story because he devotes himself
properly to god and things work out for
him
well
more or less it doesn't end very well
it doesn't but i mean good is sometimes
defeated by evil but i mean obviously he
lives a proper and admirable life and
it
it it needs to be communicated to young
people right we'll see i would say
the biblical key is always right praise
and that's i go right back to genesis
one is is
when we give praise to god drawing all
creation together then our soul becomes
ordered properly
and then around us a kingdom of right
order is built up
in the catholic mass we have that
wonderful prayer the gloria we say glory
to god in the highest
and on earth peace to people of good
will and it's a it's like a formula that
if i give god in the highest then there
will be peace around me um it's like a
condensation of the sermon on the mount
yeah exactly
that sermon seems to see that sermon
seems to me and i also believe it to be
psychologically
true
is that
it's necessary for you to
aim
at the highest
value that you can conceive of
you know and that has to have something
to do
with
the
amelioration of suffering
and
the
constraint of malevolence
it'll express itself that way naturally
yeah
as a negative and then once you
concentrate on that and focus on that
and decide that that's your your primary
aim then
things do start to order themselves
around you because well everything that
you see and do directs itself towards
that aim but that's that's this you i'd
say strangely uniquely christian thing
is that we say okay the the god that
we're worshiping the god revealed in the
old testament but then finally revealed
in jesus christ as i'm looking over my
computer screaming right now i'm looking
at the crucifix of jesus right so my
praise is directed to
a god who's entered radically into
suffering
not just physical suffering but the
whole brokenness of the world
of stupidity and cruelty and injustice
and hatred that's where god has gone so
the god that i worship is the god who
himself is dedicated to
the amelioration of suffering or of
healing the suffering of the world but
that's the way it's going to express
itself in a fallen conflictual world
right praise will end up looking like
love looking like love for those who
suffer um but see i think that's the
mess to me the master theme of the whole
bible israel always goes wrong without
exception when its praise goes wrong it
starts praising the wrong things so the
running happens in exodus when yeah
moses leads the israelites through the
desert right they they're in the same
position we're in the modern world where
where
we've escaped
a tyranny of sorts let's say or we
believe we have and entered into this
domain of untrammeled freedom and
there's nothing but
false idols calling to us from every
direction and that's that that's the
diversity idea as far as i'm concerned
because unity is certainly as profound
moral
necessity as diversity there should be
diversity within unity
and i fight it all the time you know in
in the church too because we bought into
that ideology and i said look it's the
oldest problem in philosophy the one of
the many but all we do today is we
completely valorize the many we never
see it shadow side we denigrate the one
and never see its positive side
the one is extraordinarily important
well what's your part
of god
yeah i think so the death it's the death
of that overarching unity it's the same
thing that drives
constant thoughtless criticisms of
hierarchy even though
all the biological evidence suggests you
can't even organize your perception
without using an ethical hierarchy
because you have to select from all the
things that you can choose to look at
those things that you value high enough
to attend to
so yeah
and that's our point about worship isn't
it what's the highest value to you
everything else will follow from that uh
yes if you read the paul tillich the
great protestant theologian but he said
all you need to know about a person you
can find out by asking one question what
does he worship
and everyone of course i mean sam harris
worships something worth ship what's the
highest worth to you
so then your life will be organized
accordingly the biblical idea it seems
to me is if it's other than god you will
disintegrate on the inside and the
society around you will disintegrate
yes well that's where the idea of the
logos has been so helpful yeah
yeah as a consequence we're reading you
like
if the logos is
that element
of
being let's say that's allied in some
sense with consciousness
that does in fact confront
potential and that does cast it into
reality as a consequence of ethical
choices then i can't see how it can be
otherwise then that has to be
regarded
as the
ultimate value because it's the thing
that creates
continually creates the world anew and
you know we know perfectly well that you
know you can take the opposite tackle
let's say
i don't worship
courage and truth in the face of the
potential of being and that i worship
instead cowardice and deceit
yeah and vengefulness and well then we
know where that goes you know we had
the entire 20th century as a as a
as a it's the template for that whole
thing
and the template from from from every
perspective i mean every it's obvious
it's obvious beyond a shadow of arguable
doubt
that human beings as individuals are
capable of generating something around
them that is so akin to hell even
metaphysically speaking that the
differences is is
is
you have to be
um
picayune let's say
to quibble about the difference and i do
think there's something metaphysical
about it i mean these things that we see
on earth let's say
seem to me to be reflected continually
at deeper and deeper levels of reality
you know i mean i i don't tend to talk
about
specifically religious issues because i
think that would in some sense
compromise
that the approach that i'm attempting to
take you know which is a
conciliatory approach in some sense
those who are
possessed by the scientific viewpoint
but curious about the religious point
but
um
if you abandon those initial
presuppositions that
the sovereignty of the individual the
necessity for courage in the face of
being the the moral imperative to
struggle uphill with your cross towards
the city of god i mean people understand
these things if if they're explained
carefully and they know in their souls
that they're true and yeah and they're
all over the culture that's been a
presupposition of mine doing this work
is i tend not to begin with you know
direct instruction or moral finger
wagging but i tend to begin with
something going on in the culture and
and you've talked about this you know
the the hero myth is in practically
every movie you watch but the christian
themes are every place one of the most
remarkable to me being uh i just saw it
on tv tonight was the clint eastwood's
gran torino if you want to see the best
exemplification i think in fiction
of what the church fathers meant
by the meaning of jesus cross
in other words a move of
self-sacrificing love that exposes evil
and liberates those who are under the
tyranny of evil
that's how they read the cross in a very
clever way expressed in more mythic
language you know
but the ideas are very powerful and
they're beautifully exemplified in that
movie the move that eastwood's character
makes at the end and of course as he
dies he's in the figure of the crucified
jesus unless we miss the point right
he's such an um he's it's so interesting
too because he's
i i actually made a video
um where i used a picture of
of christ delivering uh the sermon on
the mount i think and i put it
eastwood's face i superimposed it on top
of his and it was for exactly that
reason it was that
the reason that that's exemplified in
gran torino yeah because i mean eastwood
in that movie is in he's a very
harsh character very very judgmental
he's like he's like the christ that
comes back in revelations right he's
very very very judgmental right and he
give he cuts no one a break
except that he actually does like he
does separate the wheat from the chaff
and he's even
interestingly in that movie you know
he's
he ends up being more akin to the
foreigners who he hypothetically hates
like the uh
um
who's the good samaritan it's the same
ideas the good
right becomes more family to these
people that he hypothetically hates than
to his own children because he wants
them as ungrateful and unworthy and
right whereas these new immigrants are
striving to be good people yeah it's a
very interesting movie oh yeah it is and
it was a good example of uh the
principal one of my professors years ago
said the once integrated christian
vision let's say it
reformation enlightenment sort of blew
up and the pieces flew every place and
they're kind of twisted and they're
they're charred and everything and
they've landed here and there and so as
you go through the cultural landscape
you see them all over the place so
there's a there's a bit of you know
eschatology or there's christology or
there's the trinity and so on but
they're usually in distorted form so
that's a good example of there's the
christus victor theory to give his
proper name that christ is the victor
over sin and death he's conquered the
dark powers
and liberated us in the process
there it is but it's in somewhat
distorted form of course but
that's been the game i played a lot is
to try to find these these it happens
everywhere it's it's so common that it's
it's yeah well it isn't merely common
it's universal because yeah you
and this is of course one of the reasons
that i became so deeply interested in
archetypes is that
if the story doesn't have an archetypal
foundation then it's not a story i mean
something makes something a story
yeah not just a random collection of
or or images
and so it has an archetypal structure
and
you know i think what's happened in the
modern world
at least partly is this fractionation
that you've described but also something
that
a student once made me think deeply
through
she came up and asked me after a class
well if these archetypal stories are the
fundamental
the fundamental element let's say of
reality then why not just tell the
archetypal story over and over again
and i thought
well
first of all to some degree that is what
cultures did for a long time they
repeated the archetypal story but
in our modern culture
what literature seems to do is to take
the archetypal cult story and to bring
it closer to the individual it's like
it's it's brought closer to earth
um almost like the renaissance paintings
brought the
the divine figures closer to earth
closer to the actual individual say that
than the baroque paintings did
and so you have this meeting place of
the divine the archetype and the
personal that constitutes something like
popular culture
and there's some utility in that because
it's
it
it reopens a doorway to the presence of
what's missing
that's been closed by whatever
has happened to the church over the last
well what 150 years 200 years
the accelerating degeneration of the
church over the last 200 or 150 to 200
years
so i i see it as a good thing
although it isn't obvious that people
understand
that it's happening you know i explain
movies like the lion king and sleeping
beauty and so on to my audiences and
they don't know the
they don't
consciously see the
christian symbolism or the christian
symbolism in works like harry potter
which is unbelievably deep symbolic
structure i mean she she did that so
beautifully
um you know there's three making of true
grit when the coen brothers did it and
they brought and beautifully brought out
these religious themes that were not in
the john wayne version that i saw as a
kid or even like there was a remake um
kenneth branagh of cinderella and you
say it's a charming sentimental story
but it's a deeply christological telling
and he got all that and brought that out
i mean so those are there for sure i
mean within the western framework oh it
seems it doesn't seem in part look like
i've been accused let's say
although i've stopped apologizing for it
i should have stopped long ago
of fundamentally speaking to
young men
you know i mean most people on youtube
are men so there's a baseline problem
but
you know it seems to me that partly what
i'm
suggesting to
young men
is that
there really is a
an
ennobling heroism
about
the fundamental
christian vision
which is to
accept with gratitude your
privileges and your
limitations
the privileges those are talents you
have a responsibility
to make the most of them
that's the price you pay for the talents
the
um
obstacles
your limited being and you you pay a
price for being and the price is that
limitation and so you have to be
grateful
in in some strange sense for your
limitations maybe the same way that
you're grateful for the idiosyncrasies
and peculiarities of the people that you
love and then that you're that you're
that your task is an extraordinarily
difficult task there's there's no more
challenging task than to accept all that
you know with with gratitude and
with with with goodwill toward being
and to attempt
to work towards making things
better than they are or at least not
worse
and you know people understand that oh
yeah no for sure but let me press
something here because
i think all that's true from the sort of
psychological and human side the hero's
journey and our call to you know move
toward a transcendent moral good
etcetera to give ourselves for the sake
of the other but see and that's all
there within the christian and the
biblical framework but see what i think
is really interesting where the
fireworks really start
is that god has gone on a hero's journey
you know so it's not just the story of
this this human being jesus going
heroically to his cross etc but that
strangely it's god
going heroically to that place it's it's
god going into dysfunction and whatever
heroism we can summon is predicated upon
this primordial grace that was given to
us you know because the the danger
you know look i'm a catholic catholics
like faith and reason so we like to
operate both sides of that divide so
thomas aquinas constructing cosmological
arguments well good those are i think
they're fine but that's from our side of
the equation we're kind of
moving our way toward god
but the fireworks start when god moves
toward us god
god acts
and grace is operative this thing i
can't manipulate i can't control it
comes as a gift you know and so at the
cross of jesus it is clint eastwood so
there's there's a human being imitating
this great move and that's indeed what
we're called to become other christ
but he's also if you want to press it
he's that's god that's what god does god
enters into our
weird dysfunctional off-kilter world
and
suppresses evil awakens uh our freedom
and uh that's when it really gets
interesting you know it seems to me that
this has to do with this theme that i've
also popularized about
rescuing your
your dead father
yeah
from the underworld
well you know if you take on a heavy
burden
of responsibility
um
then that changes you and it it calls
forth from you things that would never
be otherwise called forth
it
partly because you encounter new things
and learn
but also because
that demands the the
the psychophysiological demands of the
confrontation
and when we know this biologically
turn on
new parts of you that are coded
genetically and
you know there's there's an immense
potential that lurks inside of human
beings and it's it's a potential of
unlimited
scope in some sense and i think that
that's
alluded to
in the idea that there's a relationship
between
logos christ and and
god and man
and that
the way that you
become closer to god
in the literal sense is
by
adopting that burden because
that transforms you into what it is that
you could be and i think that's a you
know you look the other thing you said
that was really interesting you talked
about
the fragmentation of christianity and
you know
in the old egyptian story
when osiris is
overthrown by seth who's the precursor
of satan etymologically and conceptually
osiris is willfully blind and seth is
his evil brother and seth waits for the
opportune moment and he chops osiris up
into pieces and he distributes him all
over the kingdom and so osiris can't
pull himself back together like he's
still there in nascent form because
there's no
destroying something that's divine not
permanently but you can make it very
difficult for it to get its act together
for some period of time let's say and
that fragmentation i think is
has occurred in our culture is
the death of god
i think nietzsche is wrong about that i
think it's the dismemberment of god
and not the death and
something that's dismembered can be
remembered
yeah what we need to do is to remember
and we do remember
in our literature and our art and our
popular culture that's all a form of
remembering
but we also remember when we
when we act in a way that works in
accordance with our conscience and that
sets our soul
in
into uh a configuration of peace you
know it's been fascinating
i've had
hundreds
of
and mostly young men i would say come
and talk to me after my lectures and
many of them had been in very very dark
places you know
addicted yeah alcoholic suicidal
um
chronic pornography users incapable of
settling into a committed relationship
uh
vengeful nihilistic cynical
um
and and
and also
possessed by a kind of inertia that made
them immobile
the most vital part of their youth and
you know they told me look
i decided i was going to develop a
vision for my life
i was going to imagine what things could
be
and then i was going to
try to tell the truth and i was going to
try to act responsible responsibly and
not in a praying in public manner but in
a manner that began with cleaning up my
room say a fairly humble act and
and then then comes the kicker and this
is one of the things that's kept me
going through this entire 150 city tour
they all say
and my life is way better it's like
i'm healthy i
my job is going well i've had three
promotions i'm making twice as much
money my i'm i've have i've spoken to my
father i haven't talked talked to him
for 10 years i'm putting my family
together it's like things good things
are just happening
left right and center i mean those are
amazing stories
you're in touch with the deepest rhythms
of reality it's an ethical move but it's
a metaphysical move that as you
mentioned the sermon on the mount of the
lord i mean that's how i look at it is
it's not just giving
you know moving ethical recommendations
it's trying to get us aligned to the
fundamental
non-violence of things i mean the
fundamental move of god as he gives his
rise to the world
um and so of course your life comes
together
again right praise gets you online and
knits you back together that theme to me
is really strong in the spiritual
tradition of the knitting back together
of the of the splinter itself that's
probably like you know
things
do you i mean as a psychotherapist you
deal all the time with this but like in
the scriptures
uh so you mentioned satan you know
is the accuser and there's a lot to that
but the other great word for the the
dark power is the diabolos right the
scatterer that one that divides and
separates and so the demons always
speaking in the plural in the new
testament and jesus bringing them back
to themselves back to the center but
that's that's all of us sinners i mean
we we're all over the place our mind and
will and passions and sexuality and body
they're all going different directions
and then it's the right orienting for
people it's very amusing and anxiety
provoking to be going in all those
directions yes
right and that's what do you want of us
jesus of nazareth have you come to
destroy us you know and the answer is
yes i have come to destroy this this
disparate reality and and knit you back
together so
see come here i can meet you for a
second because i i want to ask you about
that
my conviction is
atheist both old and new so the hitchens
of dawk and sam harris today but then go
back to the foyer box and nietzsche's
and company that they're they're
rebelling quite properly against a false
god what i would characterize as a false
god the god who is posing a threat to
our freedom the god who broods over us
in this moralizing and dehumanizing way
the god who i would say is a supreme
being among other beings all of that
i i applaud them i mean the atheists old
and new are rebelling against that but
it's partially because
i think i think jung saw this in his own
father right who was a calvinist
minister that we got so bad at
proclaiming the true god
who is not brooding over our freedom in
this sort of moralizing and oppressive
way he was not competing with our
flourishing but you know the glory of
god's a human being fully alive says
irenaeus that's the biblical idea or the
you know the burning bush the father's
love that is the bush that's on fire but
not consumed well that's the way the
true god relates to creation is he makes
it
beautiful and radiant but doesn't burn
it up you know we're like if somebody
the greek and roman myths when the gods
break in things have to give way or
they're they're incinerated or they're
destroyed
but the bible presents this very
unique and and
humanizing view of god
and then culminating in in the
incarnation god becomes one of us
without that's why it's so beautiful to
me and those those seemingly abstract
formulas about you know the two natures
that come together in jesus without
mixing mingling and confusion you say
well that's a lot of these greek
abstractions but no that's it's very
powerful that god and humanity can meet
in such a way that humanity is not
overwhelmed and destroyed see but that's
what the atheists quite rightly old and
new are objecting to is precisely that
false understanding of god but we
thought of nietzsche as a
as
he's it's it's a very
disturbing analogy but
i've always thought of nietzsche playing
the same role as maggots to cleaning
yeah you know i mean i'm not
he's a very sophisticated thinker and to
think of nietzsche's simply as an
atheist i think is a is a is a terrible
mistake i mean he certainly had plenty
of good things to say about catholicism
about the fact that catholicism was an
anti-diabolical
movement that united europe united yeah
right you know under under the rubric of
a single
of a single mode of thought and
discipline the european mind and he also
had wonderful things to say about christ
as a figure you know he said well need
to believe that the only true christian
was christ and
his criticism was essentially saved
for the dogmatic structure of the church
now you know i actually have more
sympathy for dostoevsky who i think
thought more deeply about this than
nietzsche which is quite a frightening
thing to say because nietzsche is such a
deep
thinker but you know in
in uh
in the grand inquisitor
when when christ comes back to earth and
and is then
arrested by this seville
by the grand inquisitor of sevilla of
seville in the during the spanish
inquisition
you know the the grand inquisitor takes
christ into the cell and tells him why
it's necessary for him to be put to
death again he says you know
the church has worked diligently to
humanize the impossible load that you've
placed on people and and to make it
bearable for the common man and the last
thing we need is someone as
perfect as you
and and terrifying as a consequence as a
judge because something that perfect is
a judge coming back to mess up all our
work and you know that's a sympathetic
portrayal of catholicism i would say
or maybe orthodox christianity as well
that that it had that merciful element
that
the demand for perfection was was was
was
was antithetical too but then of course
dostoevsky has the brilliance to
when the grand inquisitor leaves
hypothetically having
having sentenced christ to death he
leaves the door open and i've often
thought that that's so true of
catholicism and orthodox christianity
protestantism as well is that for all
their faults and for all the faults that
people like nietzsche and hitchens and
dawkins etc
uh lay at the feet of these traditions
they at least did preserve the tradition
and leave the door open and that's not
an easy thing to do over the course of
of centuries i i think the institutions
deserve a certain amount of sympathy
even though i'm very concerned that
they're
degenerating and disintegrating in a
manner that doesn't look easily
forestallable
can i let me ask you a quick question
about the brothers karamazov because you
know twice in my life i tried to read it
and i think i just got bogged down with
the russian name stuff so i failed both
times i got a little further the second
time but then just about six months ago
i got an audio of it
because i'm in the car all the time in
california going back and forth
and i'm just about finished with it i
love it love it it finally just it sang
to me as this guy read the thing you
know yeah it's amazing it's amazing how
powerful it is on audio it's wonderful
wonderful how do you read first of all
the silence of christ in the presence of
the inquisitor but then secondly his the
kiss the kiss on the lips at the end you
know so he sits in silence as this great
accusation is is read
uh but then kisses him full on the lips
at the end
well i think i think he accepts the
accusation like one of the things jung
said about christ in the gospels which i
thought was it was indescribably
brilliant
was that
christ not entirely but is presented as
a figure of mercy
and jung was wise enough to know that
and and he used religious sources for
this idea that
god rules
with two hands with mercy and with
justice because
if it's just mercy then well all is
always forgiven and you have no
responsibility and you're an eternal
infant
but if it's all justice then look out
because every single transgression you
you
you commit you'll be held
to account for in some infinite manner
and people are so fallible that
well you kind of see that happening in
on twitter now you know if you if you
make a mistake
of any sort at any point in your life
you're you're
roasted over the open coals for it and
no one can stand that because everyone
makes mistakes and so there has to be
this balance between mercy and justice
young regarded christ's return in
revelation as psychologically necessary
because
any figure of perfection
has this element of the judge because
any ideal is a judge yeah and so
um yeah you can't bracket that in the
name of of because the master category
is love right and not to be sentimental
about it love means to will the good of
the other so that always has a
judgmental dimension of course it does
because if you have a child or a friend
or yourself it's like and i felt this
when i was a psychotherapist practicing
as a psychotherapist i mean roger said
well you had to have unconditional love
for your client and i thought no
i have unconditional
positive regard for the part of my
client that's driving toward the light
and i'm a co-enemy with that part
against the part that's trying to drag
that person down and then i tell you
can i tell you that an entire generation
of catholic priests was formed
under the rigerian assumption because
that's what what my generation got now i
mean i learned things from rogers and
the whole
it works in a way when i was doing
pastoral ministry and counseling early
on as a young priest you know that whole
idea of just kind of mirroring back to
someone what they're saying and giving
them the i mean i get it i get it but i
agree with you there's a severe danger
in that if that's all we're doing with
people we're not moving them in the
manner of a spiritual teacher
i had a student years ago said to me
what we're missing from the church is
yoda on our shoulders you know he meant
yoda on the shoulders of luke skywalker
instructing him and pressing him and
telling him what he's doing wrong and
how to get going you know that we were
we were all rogerians we just were
unconditionally positive regarding
everybody but we weren't it's a great
it's a great compliment see the other
thing that it's made me popular among
young people this is so perverse i don't
know i have a hard time believing any of
it really i mean the first thing
that i have a hard time believing is
that
you know i can
attract audiences of
5 000 people and tell them that
the problem with their lives is that
they're not bearing nearly enough
responsibility and that's where they're
going to find the meaning that sustains
them it's a pretty rough message yeah
and the second thing is especially with
young people because the message has
been fifth for 50 years and this is part
of the humanists from the 1960s is
well you're okay the way you are yeah
and i think
there isn't anything more damning that
you can call a young person right well
you're okay the way you are especially
if they're suffering and nihilistic it's
like well get me out of where i am i
want to get out of this state
that's right they want to crawl right
out of their skin and so you tell them
instead no look man you don't know
anything you're you're barely beginning
you're you're
you're you're suffering because in a
sense because you are steeped in sin to
an almost unimaginable degree and i'm
saying that compassionately
right judgmentally and and that if you
want to put your life together
you have to start small and you have to
be careful and awake and if you do it
carefully then you can eliminate these
flaws in your character that no one
should be right celebrating
and right people light up when you tell
them that yes right so strange
it was a real pastoral failure on the
part of the church as i was coming of
age because we were we were reacting
against maybe a hyper stress on sin so
my parents generation probably got that
especially sexual sin so i understand
that there was a hyper reaction but that
is exactly the problem is you ended up
with a generation of catholics that felt
like okay god is love i'm okay
everything will be fine
so then there's no energy there's no
directionality there's no sense of
purpose there's no sense of spiritual
struggle there's no evil
right there's no real evil everything
dealing with you know situations like
nazi germany
right right but uh no that was a huge
pastoral failure one was intellectual as
coming of age we became very deeply
anti-intellectual and this problem of a
hyper kind of rigerian you know
rajarianization of our pastoral practice
uh see i like to i like rogers a lot
because one of the things rogers really
taught me to do was to listen
yeah right yes advice about listening
and then
restating to people what you heard yeah
so that sounds like with you
that that's unbelievably powerful
because it does of course you listen and
but rogers was a seminarian and he did
dispense with the idea of evil and the
devil fundamentally and he fell into the
trap of rousseau where you know the idea
was that people were basically good and
that's just
it's such a devaluation of people to say
that they're basically good because
it's it's clearly the case that people
have an unbelievable capacity for
malevolence that and to me that's that's
heartening you know
yeah
like again i can talk to my audiences
and i can say look all you guys just you
sit on the edge of your bed and you
think about all the things that you're
doing wrong that you know that you're
doing wrong way that you're leading
yourself and other people astray
those things will come to your mind
momentarily and imagine briefly where
that would take you if you allowed your
imagination to take you to where
it could in its depths and everyone nods
their head because they bloody well know
and they're saying
imagine just for a moment that if you
have that capacity for absolute mayhem
and malevolence that the opposite is
also true because if there is that
darkness and that evil then obviously
the opposite also exists and yeah and
then it's also possible to make a case
for people to people that they can
believe
that
good has the capability of triumphing
over evil but you don't do that by
minimizing evil you do it by maximizing
evil that's right i mean i would say
part of spiritual direction is helping
people see what they're really capable
of and i mean that in the negative sense
help people to see like i'm really
capable of some really wicked business
and if i'm hiding from that all the time
i'm suppressing it all the time that's
not the thing because from now a
religious standpoint you want to say
christ goes all the way down now that's
the descent in the health theme but that
happens in us he goes all the way down
in me to the bottom of my dysfunction
and people like dostoyevsky are really
good at showing that dimension of life
but if we don't do that spiritually then
then we're not understanding the cross
right understanding redemption uh
salvation that we're healed by this
downward journey of the son of god but
he goes with us there's dante now
there's the journey downward through all
the levels of our dysfunction till you
find
i think he's dead right about that you
find some originating
dysfunction so the satan whose wings
beat the air and and create the you know
atmosphere of hell there's something in
me that's generating all the different
levels of dysfunction yeah but until i
find that i'm not going to solve it i
got to go all the way down no the
inferno is right is that there there's
just like there's a hierarchy of good
there's a hierarchy of evil and right
dante places the betrayers at the bottom
right right and cassius
because
you know
one of the
necessities of
positive interpersonal existence even
with yourself
much less or let alone other people is
trust like essential trust yeah and it's
a form of courage another thing i talk
to my audiences about is trust because
like
we we tend in our society to worship
naive trust by making the claim that
people are basically good
and the problem with that and this is
what entices so many young people into
that nihilistic atheism is that
they're taught this idea
and then they're betrayed very badly by
themselves or by some other person and
that's the death of innocence and so
then they go from
naivety
to cynicism
and cynicism is actually an improvement
over naivety
but but it's not the end and then they
don't know that because the next step is
to
trust
as a consequence of courage
and to say look i'm going to extend my
hand once again to myself
or to my friend or to my family member
despite the fact that i've already been
betrayed and hurt because
by extending that hand again i
allow the person the possibility of
redemption and
and i open up a space for us to rekindle
a productive relationship but that's
predicated on courage and not naivety i
know that
yeah it's like it's like
stretching out a hand to it to a dog
that's frightened and barking and looks
looking like it's going to bite you know
it's
it's still the best way if you're
careful to
to establish
peace let's say with that animal
and and
the problem with the betrayers
is that they take trust which is
the most fundamental necessity for
interpersonal relationships and then
they violate the very
principle of trust
and it undermines everything and so
that's why they're at the bottom of hell
that's why
brutus and judas are there uh
you know it reminds me of the story of
francis and the wolf of gubeo francis
you know it's like a dream that story
francis reaching out to the animal
that's been that's been threatening the
town you know and
frightening everybody but francis has
the trust to reach out to the animal and
then he tames it and then you know makes
a deal if you feed the animal then he
won't you know harm you and so on but
it's
it doesn't jung say a lot of dreams when
animals function that way if dimensions
of ourselves that we're kind of
that's a dream for sure because what it
is is that you know there's a part of
you that's ravenous and yeah malevolent
and not being fed properly right and
that's often because you're not
attending to it you're you're putting it
in a blind corner and it's it's acting
out because it demands recognition and
like people do this with their own
with the power that gives them integrity
you know i've had clients and i would
say they were more often female than
than male
um who had this particular problem but
who had a very acute and judgmental
intelligence
um very very bright people but they were
also unbelievably agreeable
and so their intelligence would report
to them something that was not
positive about someone you know it would
see around the corner it would seem a
hidden motivation and reveal a negative
truth and the person temperamentally was
so shocked by the revelation that
instead of regarding it as a genuine
insight they felt that there was
something wrong with them for thinking
that way and then that's the same thing
as keeping that ravenous wolf
um
unfed it's like
the the particular client i'm thinking
about i spent hours talking to her about
what she thought about people because
she was a very pleasant person and it it
caused her a lot of trouble she was far
too much mercy and not nearly enough
justice and a lot of insights into the
malevolent
motivations of people were unbelievably
accurate and deep yeah almost completely
incapable of
allowing that to be real
it reminds me of
we mentioned the cohen brothers earlier
their remake of true grit you remember
the young girl in that who's just she's
seized by justice she wants to get
revenge because her father was killed
then she just and people people are
dying around her corpses are piling up
because she's just going to get what she
wants and then of course she's bit by
the snake which has a certain archetypal
overtone and she loses her arm you know
but she's carried after the snakebite
she's carried in the two arms of of uh
rooster cogburn you know who's a law man
he's a man of justice but you find out
that he's he's also a man of mercy he's
a man of
deep human connection
and
the the story is prefaced by the lion
there's only one thing in the world
that's truly free and that's the grace
of god and i just thought it's that
wonderful so the grace of god is not
just mercy and not just justice it's the
two arms of it she ends up she's all
justice so the the one arm is missing
brewster's got the two arms able to
carry her you know but i think that's
what we've been missing a lot in the
church is the two arms um
we've become just too much for a mercy
church in a way i don't that's what i
think of like i don't think that you
guys ask enough of your yeah no you're
you're not you're not giving them hell
yeah no i think there's something right
about that and that's the yoda on your
shoulder so is there someone who's kind
of pushing me and telling me and
teaching me and bringing me on that
downward journey like
the virgil move that you're gonna
accompany this person all the way down
now the importance here's why pope
francis is really good because
accompaniment and the church is a field
hospital he says for people deeply
wounded that's really right
and we got to accompany people though
all the way down my generation got i
think a very superficial sort of you
know everything's okay god is love and
you'll be fine um but that led to a lot
of drift and see when my generation came
of age and we got hit by life
i can testify there's a lot of my
classmates they left religion in a
heartbeat because we got a very
superficial childish one-sided approach
but then life hits all of us inevitably
and they religion had nothing for them
right right
and that's exactly when it's necessary
yeah and you know
love is a terrible thing right harsh and
dreadful things no if you love your
children
you
you don't let them
get away with anything right you club on
their trans questions and that's very
um i remember you know
this situation with my son when he was
about
four or five
and uh
i had a really good have a really good
relationship
with my son
but i you know i've always
assumed that he
had the capability to make intelligent
judgments and expected him to do so from
a very early age yeah and you know when
he was four
he was talking to me and i thought he
was lying to me
and i didn't know because i couldn't
tell but you know
that internal damon was saying no
there's something that's not right here
and i wasn't going to let him get away
with it because i couldn't let him
learn that
it was acceptable to do that or that i
would put up with it
and so i told him in this weird thing
it's kind of like pharaoh or it's kind
of like god hardening
pharaoh's heart i said look kid
here's the deal
i think you're lying to me
and that we can't have that
but if you're not i want you to put up
like a tremendous fight here to defend
yourself
because if you're being honest well then
i want to know that but i'm not gonna
back off because i don't believe
that what you're saying is true
and so
i went after him you know for a good
long while and it did turn out that he
was telling me something that wasn't
true which
hardly came as a relief you know
i mean children do that and it wasn't a
surprise to me
but
that that love is if you really love
someone
you
you can't tolerate
when they're
less
than they
could be
right it hurts and so when someone comes
into the church
and it's all forgiveness
yeah there's no care there it's like
what the hell are you doing look at you
you're addicted you're you're
you're you're
hooked on pornography you cheat on your
wife you're doing a terrible job at work
it's like you're you don't take care of
yourself it's like what the hell is
wrong with you it's like where's the
real you yeah the person
anyone
who is subject to that as long as it's
done with care you know and not i'm
better than you which is the right thing
it's like
god man
you're
you're nothing
like
[Music]
you should be yeah
and if you don't do that you're not
willing the good of the other in fact
you're trying to move into an easy space
if i'm nice this person who'll be nice
to me and we'll all be happy but that's
not love that's the kind of mentality no
conflict it's a new conflict
it reminds me
at the beginning of the inferno when
dante you know he sees the hill with
light on it oh there it is that's where
i need to go i know i'm lost i'm in the
wood but that's where i need to go and
off he goes but then he's blocked by the
three animals right with the wolf and
the leopard and the line i think
so there's no easy route that's the
point there's no easy route to that hill
you've got to go
down and all the way down but i think we
we probably did tell our people that it
was too easy a route you know
everything's okay you're okay god is
love but then everyone god is loving and
love is nice love is harsh and dreadful
right that's the
thing but love is harsh and dreadful
right and they'll find out soon enough
that the road is blocked everyone does
but then what's the way forward and
there should be spiritual masters in
place
that know exactly what to do the virgil
move i know what we got to do here we
got to do a searching moral inventory
and go all the way down
well and that's that that's the descent
before the ascent
right you know right because that's a
classical fall of man's story it's the
story of exodus it's part of the reason
that people aren't enlightened it's that
if you're going to go up man
every up
is predicated by a down of equivalent
magnitude right because look if you're
if you're going to improve
you're going to discover that you're
wrong about something
first
and then to be wrong about something
means you're going to fragment and and
it's going to be painful to recognize
the fact of that error to recognize the
consequences of that error across your
life
to have to reformulate yourself so that
that error is no longer
acting out as as part of your
personality in your life it's it's an
unbelievable descent
yeah that's another thing that that this
is part of the reason why
for all the respect i have for joseph
campbell you know campbell says follow
your bliss
and that is certainly not something that
jung said
because jung said
you search out what you're most
terrified of and what you're most
disgusted by and
the place you least want to go
where you have to bow the lowest yeah
and that's the place where salvation
might be found and that's like and i
believe that's true and i believe it's
terrifying
the the the pathway to redemption is
through recognition of error not through
bliss
right
that was where campbell got enamored of
a kind of mindless buddhism
yeah the only way up is down and that's
that's in all the spiritual teachers all
right go back to origin you mentioned
exodus you know where he says that the
egyptians and the israelites symbolize
the best of us
is often enslaved to the worst of us so
the egyptians the slave masters
represent the worst instincts in us and
the most twisted and dysfunctional
aspects of us and the israelites
symbolized he felt our creativity our
intelligence our courage all these good
things our friendship willingness to
move forward
yeah but the best of us is enslaved to
the worst of us and so you got to come
to terms with who are the egyptians in
you and they're making you do two things
he says they're making you build
fortified cities for them so we take the
best of ourselves to build
fortifications around the worst of
ourselves to protect them and they build
uh monuments so hey look at me so i mean
how much of life he says is spent doing
those two dysfunctional things defending
the worst of ourselves and then building
monuments to the worst of ourselves when
in fact
get free of that and get to the promised
land but i mean he's he was the original
master of all that psychodynamic reading
i think of these of these texts well
it's also surprising that
so few people know
what a multiplicity of readings yeah the
bible has actually
because we get hung up on this goofy
fundamentalism which is a 20th century
phenomenon you know the scopes trail
stuff and all that we in america
especially but in the west we got hung
up on it you read augustine who is
deeply indebted to origin you've got
these very creative interpretive
strategies in place around genesis for
example it's not literalism by any means
and that's we're talking origin we're
talking the third century irenaeus
second century augustine fourth century
and these are really early figures and
these are not
thinkers right they're not hung up on
liberalism right
so i yes we need to recover that i think
even as as christians our own
biblical interpretive tradition
so what are you hoping for in the coming
year
for you and for what you're doing
what am i hoping for
yeah what would you like to see happen
as a consequence of what you're doing
and what what do you think you are doing
i mean you're on this public i wouldn't
call it a crusade
but you're you're engaging with the
public you know in this new way and it
seems to be it seems to be quite
successful
and yeah what do you think it is that
you're doing right and what would you
like to see happen as a consequence of
that
i think what i what i'm doing right is
uh beginning with the summing of arabi
it's the church father's idea the seeds
of the word the seeds of the word are
everywhere or that's the bits of the
fragmented catholicism that are found in
the culture so i tend to begin with the
culture
and lead from there i think that is more
winsome so i tend not to begin with a
lot of preaching or or you know
a moralizing approach but begin with a
cultural approach and i think that's
been more
appealing i mean if i wanted to my
ultimate goal is i want to bring people
to faith in christ in the catholic
church i mean that's my ultimate goal
i'm an evangelizer but i'm using certain
methods to try to draw people to that
point
realizing that there's an awful lot of
obstacles in the way you know
i'm trying to kick open some doors i'm
trying to
part of it is
to help people with their intellectual
blocks there's so many especially
younger people they're just stuck
because certain intellectual objections
have occurred to them and they've heard
them from their university professors or
whatever
to clear up some of that to knock over
some of those obstacles that's part of
it but then to open up and i think
that's what you're doing too i mean open
up the richness of this spiritual
tradition
because
it it makes people it's not just an
intellectual
feast it it saves your soul you know
that's what i want to do i want to help
people
you know your fellow canadian charles
taylor the great catholic philosopher uh
talks about the buffered self the self
that's caught in this little space
there's no sense of a link to the
transcendent that's what i'm trying to
do i'm trying to knock holes in the in
the buffer itself and let in some light
from a higher you know dimension of
reality so i mean ultimately it's to
bring people to salvation and say what i
want to do but knock some holes in the
buffer itself i want to keep doing that
um
and i said this i was in rome in october
we had this month-long synod with the
pope on
young people and i was elected to go to
that synod
and it was interesting you know like
what's our strategy for reaching young
people and i said
i think
a miracle of providence right now is we
have this massive problem of young
people leaving but we have this new tool
of the social media which we didn't have
i mean heck 10 years ago we couldn't do
this and now we can reach out to young
people into their space
because catholic we tend to say
what programs can we develop you know
lecture series that we can develop well
people aren't coming to our institutions
for all kinds of reasons but we can sort
of move into their space with the social
media so that's kind of how i see what
i'm up to and you know trying to do
be nice to see if something could be
done with all those beautiful cathedrals
yeah well that's um i wrote about them
years ago i studied in paris
i studied in paris and uh i used to give
tours at notre dame and uh
i was a doctoral student i was a priest
a doctoral student and uh we were told
by the tour guides now don't talk about
religion so we're just meant to talk
about you know how tall the building was
and what it was built but i used it to
sermonize really to talk about the
christian faith
and uh i've written a little book on the
spirituality of the cathedrals you know
i'd like to i'd like to read that i mean
are is there a decent bibliography in
that book because i'm really interested
in cathedral architecture no and i am
too the little i wrote this years ago
it's a little book of kind of spiritual
meditation so it wouldn't be you know
with an academic apparatus um but i read
a lot of those books at the time and and
love the cathedrals too because they're
they're just talk about you know like
moving into a dream space of the
archetypal realities are all over the
place
uh chart
is my favorite place in the world maybe
my favorite
covered space in the world is shark
cathedral
why why that cathedral
i i don't think anything is richer i
remember spending a weekend there i went
down from paris on a friday just got a
hotel room and i stayed there until mass
on sunday and i made sure i saw
everything in it i walked all around the
outside all over the inside
and
the my old testament imagination was so
engaged by shark you know because
there's your thing about the the
allegorical they they read the old
testament in constant relation to christ
you know it's a fulfillment
uh and the sculpture i mean god the
sculpture is just incomparably beautiful
in its execution but then the windows
there are no better windows and there
most of them are real medieval windows
from the 13th century
nothing sings to me more just the way
it's situated the topography of it you
know you kind of come up to chart and
when you go back behind it you
you take the pilgrims route up to it and
all of that the pilgrims journey is
implicit there but the windows look like
um
they look like diamonds on a black
velvet background they're like jewels
and it's the it's the shining jewels of
the new jerusalem so there's the
anagogical sense it's all about the
journey to heaven and then the um the
labyrinth which unfortunately has been
kind of co-opted by a new agey
spirituality but the original labyrinth
that most of the ones we see today
imitate is there it's sharp yes and i
know the labyrinth is an amazing thing
it's extraordinary i walked it i've
watched it several times and it's a very
powerful experience
anyway shard has all of that in it and
and more you know
yes well it's such a shame that these
these buildings that you know you see
what happened in europe but i i don't
understand it is that europe went
through this several hundred years long
period of time where
beauty was
worshiped
in a profound way and see them
manifested in the construction of these
great cathedrals that took centuries to
build and they were these people were
well the bricklayer wasn't just laying
bricks the bricklayer was building a
cathedral to god honoring god yeah which
is how our lives should be right in his
yeah every little thing that we do
should be
imbued without higher vision which is
possible if you have that higher vision
and you know the the contribution of
that
vision to europe and to world cultures
is absolutely priceless i mean people
make pilgrimages from all over the world
to view these
insanely
beautiful and complex buildings and they
were driven by a spirit that was
well
hopefully unconquerable but certainly
of sufficient potency even in a
fundamentally atheistic age to pull
people in for reasons they don't really
even understand just the
sheer awe
at the what at the daring of the
architects and it talked about a door or
window a transcendent that's the way of
punching through the buffer itself those
cathedrals and don't get me started on
church architecture the last you know
like 40 50 years when we largely adopted
a kind of brutalist modernism within
catholicism and built uh what vaults are
called the great barns you know these
big empty spaces and we wonder you know
then why are the young people leaving in
droves the church building itself didn't
sing to them in any way which they used
to do even though like imitation gothic
buildings from the from the 1930s but
man a young catholic coming of age at
that time was i mean look at that i'm
just surrounded by the imagery of the
faith and the whole narrative of
salvation and
i was just an orbeez and the in
incarnation of the
stone you know talked about part of the
goal of salvation let's say to bring
everything together to have everything
to come together in a kind of integrity
and
right with a kind of integrity in any
union and of course music
portrays that better than anything else
as far as i'm concerned and those
cathedrals were symphonies in stone
absolutely then they they they portrayed
architecturally exactly what music
attempts to portray
orally
and and and it works i mean
it works oh gosh yeah and they're
comparable has no belief
right absolutely and you know it's a big
of a cliche to say it but the the
sumo of aquinas and the and the divine
comedy of dante are like that they have
that same kind of quality of of
integration and like the whole of life
being on display
and that's part of what fell apart you
know that we that we we needed the
critique of enlightenment for sure i
mean i get it we needed that in a lot of
different ways but sadly often that
critique got overstated and we baby
bathwater phenomenon and a lot of the
the integrity was compromised uh how do
you keep the critique without throwing
out the substance you know it's been one
of the struggles
and much of the of the theology of the
last couple hundred years has been so
conditioned by the enlightenment
criticism
i mean i get it and take it in for sure
but don't so condition your theology by
that critique that you lose all this
stuff that we're talking about now that
has the soul transforming power well
that's it you know it seems to me that
it's
and this is so necessary is that it's
there's something
what's required is a
re-emphasis on the potential nobility of
the human being and and the moral
responsibility to make that nobility a
reality don't even talk about words like
that like i use the word nobility in my
lectures and it's such an archaic word
it's like we should have a noble goal
it's like who what child is told that
now
yeah no and and
we're built for nobility
well i mean you're a psychotherapist
obviously but it seems to me that we're
so concerned about people's feelings and
that the feelings getting hurt or
getting repressed or something that
we're afraid if we use that language of
a noble aspiration or come on you can do
better okay you've got a serious problem
that it'll awaken such negative feelings
leading eventually to
you know self-mutilation or suicide at
the limit that we're so afraid of that
that we're we're reluctant to use the
language of nobility yes well we're
we're afraid of hurting people's
feelings and feelings in the present
and willing to absolutely sacrifice
their well-being in the future and
that's the sign of a very immature and
unwise culture because
the reverse should be the case
yeah you know it's like
look and you said already
there's no up without doubt yeah and
that initial conversation when you lay
things bare you put everything out on
the table and you discuss what the
problems are
and maybe the potential solutions man
that's a rough conversation yeah you
know it's it's almost more than people
can bear but if it's a discussion of
reality well they're already bearing it
and at least
placing it on the table indicates that
well that there's someone who's willing
to listen and that it isn't so terrible
that like voldemort it can't be named
right now that's been exactly my
argument i alluded to it earlier that
when you say oh my god there'll be too
much for people to take see but but life
is gonna force itself on them life will
force them into this and then there
won't be any wisdom or or guide to help
them with it so if we say look i'm so
concerned about sparing people's
feelings heck life doesn't care about
your feelings your nature doesn't care
about your feelings well that's one of
the things i learned from young and he
was very very
and i think this is a psychotherapeutic
truism
is that
if you're going to confront a monster
and you most certainly are yeah then you
do it at a time and place of your
choosing yeah because otherwise it waits
until you're at your weakest and most
vulnerable and then it attacks and so
there is no
monster free pathway forward no that's
right to prepare
as a knight of christ let's say
so that when it comes you're
there or in fact confronting it
at its weakest point or you cower and
you wait and it devours you and yeah
those are your options and we don't have
the
wisdom of the kind of pessimism that
enables us to view life that way we
think well
if we're careful and we're quiet
well the monster will avoid this
completely and everyone knows that's a
lie
yeah oh gosh yeah do you find this uh
because sometimes when i use this
language
people say well yeah that's great for
the young men but the young ladies don't
respond to it but years ago my niece
who's now she's what almost 30 i guess
when she was about 17 they took on one
of these these nature things you know
where they took the kids out into the
woods and they had to hike and they had
to build their own campfire and then
they had to forward streams and they had
you know it's one of these really
demanding things where they were up
against nature and up against life
man did she come back
utterly transformed as a human being in
a way that religion had never done she'd
been catholic all her life gone to mass
her uncle's a bishop but there's nothing
in in the in our faith that changed her
the way that experience clearly changed
her
serious conversation to be had with
young women you know a woman
asked me a question on my q a this month
she said that
her friends are really down on her
because she
claims to not be a feminist but even
more importantly because she wants to
have children and they're telling her
that
only an evil and cruel person would
bring a child into a world is terrible
and and worse to do the damage to the
planet that that child will
do and the people are very serious about
this and they're very hard on young
women and like i always think of the
paeda you know because i kind of think
of it as the
as the christian equivalent of the
crucifix you know you have mary there
with her broken son in her arms and i
think that
the the the great adventure for women at
least in part
this is the maternal adventure is to
bring a child into the world knowing
full well that the consequences the
consequence is
a crucifixion like brokenness
yeah and that it's still a mark of faith
in the possibilities of being to
participate in that
and not to hide from it and to say well
despite everything i'm going to
act out my faith in life and in and in
the possibilities of being and i'm going
to bring someone into the world who will
be a net force for good rather than evil
and that's my moral obligation and i
think to present that to young women as
a major part of the adventure of their
life which is certainly the truth is
something that's attractive to far more
of them than
would be likely to admit it in today's
time and age
yeah i'm glad to use the word faith
there because just a couple days ago we
had the feast of saint joseph you know
and joseph in the new testament is like
abraham in the old testament he's the
paradigmatic person of faith right
so i was talking to a group of high
school kids
and i said okay listen to me everybody i
know you're going to hear this from your
professors in college and you probably
hear it already that faith means
you know being
uncritical and you accept any old
nonsense on the basis of no evidence
that it's superstition and
you say look we're against that and i
speak now as a catholic
faith and reason we don't want anything
subrational anything that it's a lie and
and you know it
that's irresponsible and it's stupid and
you know it it's irresponsible to accept
it so that's not faith you know but i
said what close what you just said
faith in the bible is this
willingness to risk
under the providence of god some great
adventure yeah that's exactly right
here's joseph you know that braves
phrases yeah no i think that's that's it
and that's what faith means in the bible
it doesn't mean oh i'm an idiot and just
tell me any old nonsense and i'll
believe it it means no it means that
adventure right that's the other thing
is that one of the things i really
learned from reading the abrahamic
stories is that
the fundamental call
is to is it called to adventure yeah
easier to happiness and and even the
adventure
the part of
the relationship with god that's part of
that adventure is wrestling with god
yeah yeah israel itself means is that
it's another aspect of that strange
element of belief is like what does it
mean to believe well it means to adopt
this moral burden but it also means to
wrestle with god yeah right and not to
not to
blindly accept
preposterous blandishments that no one
with any sense would ever swallow
right but i think we've been again
pretty bad at propagating that if the
new atheists have got an awful lot of
traction with that idea that religious
people are just sort of naive and
superstitious and uncritical then we
haven't explained very well what we mean
by faith um
they certainly haven't explained the
element of it that's associated with
courage
no right and and but then under the
guidance of a spiritual uh
master that will help you through that
and push you toward the edge and help
you navigate those waters and that's
dante got that all of our great
spiritual teachers have it but we've not
been good at that in my judgment you
know
well
maybe we'll learn
before it's too late
yeah that would be nice
i guess i should probably stop
we've gone from about 90
it was really a pleasure talking with
you yeah i loved it jordan thank you
very much i was delighted i'd like to
have another conversation a darker one i
would say i've been reading
a book have you read in the closet of
the vatican okay i did yeah i did
it's a bad book but i mean well let's
talk about it i'd be happy to i would
like to have a conversation about when
i'm more prepared for it because i'm
sure i am prepared for it enough yet i
did read it because i figured everybody
would be talking about it and uh it's
it's a bad book in many ways meaning i
think it's poorly researched and all
that but um sure let's talk about it all
right all right welcome
let's call it a date all right
all right great thank you for having me
on
well thank you for coming on and and um
we'll get this up and out as soon as
possible both in youtube and audio forum
and nice and i guess we'll see what the
consequences are we'll see
you do find out on youtube pretty
quickly you do um
more power to you as far as i'm
concerned and and
and thank you very much for spending the
time speaking with me today yeah god
bless you thanks
bye bye okay